herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
ja die deutsche lieben unseren wald aber
nicht nur dichter und denker
spaziergänger und romantiker schätzt den
wald näher ist für uns alle wichtig denn
der wald spiel die zentrale rolle beim
klimaschutz
nun ist es aber so dass der schützer
selber schutz braucht wir alle wissen es
der deutsche wald ist in katastrophalem
zustand die extrem trockenen sommer in
den letzten jahren haben dem wald
kräftig zugesetzt in unter stress
gebracht und der borkenkäfer als einer
von vielen schädlingen hat es nun
leichtes spiel
was tun wie soll der deutsche wald in
der zukunft aussehen was kann man tun um
den klimaschützer walz globus zu machen
in zeiten des klimawandels das thema
heute beim nationalen wald gipfel bei
dem mehrere hundert waldbesitzer
wissenschaftler und politiker
teilgenommen haben und thema eben auch
bei uns wir reden mit der
landwirtschaftsministerin aus
nordrhein-westfalen ursula heinen esser
die beim wald gipfel mit dabei war wir
wollen sprechen mit leiser forstexperte
und verfechter einer naturnahen
waldbewirtschaftung und wir haben als
drittem gesprächspartner auch noch
hubert aiwanger stellvertretender
ministerpräsident in bayern dort
wirtschaftsminister und on top auch noch
selbst waldbesitzer zunächst aber alle
zahlen daten fakten zum desolaten
zustand unseres waldes deutschlands wald
11,1 millionen hektar gibt es das heißt
fast ein drittel ist hierzulande mit
bäumen bedeckt doch der wald ist krank
in den vergangenen drei jahren haben ihm
drei dinge zugesetzt stürme
extreme dürre und borkenkäferbefall die
folge flächen von insgesamt 277 1000
hektar sind beschädigt hinzu kommt
verstärkte rodung vergangenes jahr gab
es einen rekord 80,4 millionen
kubikmeter holz wurden geschlagen bedarf
für den bauboom hierzulande und für
starke nachfrage in der eu den usa und
in china weniger wald das schadet auch
dem klima denn bäume binden das
treibhausgas co2 am besten können dass
laubbäume buche und co in deutschland
entlasten die atmosphäre jährlich um
rund 52 millionen tonnen kohlendioxid
deutschlands wald auch ein klimaschutz
faktor
die zahlen der zustand erschrecken
waldbesitzer wissenschaftler und
politiker haben deshalb beim nationalen
wald gipfel heute beraten was ist zu tun
wir können jetzt lesen reden mit ursula
heinen esser der
landwirtschaftsministerin in
nordrhein-westfalen sie waren heute mit
dabei beim nationalen falls gipfel frau
ministerin erklären sie uns einfach mal
was ist bei rausgekommen was sind die
entscheidenden beschlüsse und punkte der
wesentliche punkt ist erstmal dass wir
uns untereinander darüber ausgetauscht
haben wie schwierig die situation im
wald zur zeit ist sie haben die zahlen
ja gerade in dem beitrag schon sehr
eindrucksvoll genannt und für uns steht
immer noch an allererster stelle
die schäden im wald zu beseitigen wir
sind überhaupt noch nicht bei der
wiederaufforstung sondern wir sind immer
noch bei der schwanz beseitigung von
drei jahre dürfen und borkenkäfer und
ich hoffe dass es dieses jahr nicht so
wird was ist beschlossen waren oder was
ist besprochen worden
herzstück wird ein neues instrument sein
dass der bund einführen wird hoffentlich
bald nämlich eine baum premier oder die
anna klima prämie wie man ist auch immer
auch sagen will nämlich die anerkennung
der ökologischen leistungen die die
arbeit für uns bringen
das gab es bisher nicht als instrument
und das soll neu eingeführt werden
das heißt könnte ich soll weit wenn er
zertifiziert ist auch wenn er bestimmte
ferien erfüllt soll dann quasi dafür
bezahlt werden also in dem fall der
waldbesitzer dass sein weil diese
leistung erbringt und damit haben wir
eine gute chance auch wirklich klima
stabilen mischwald bei uns hin zu
bekommen der dann auch mit dem
klimawandel besser zurechtkommt und dem
klimaschutz dient also sie haben schon
mal kurz angeschnitten ich war neue
ideen neue wege neue förderungen wir
schauen dass einfach in einem beitrag
mal kurz und kompakt an worum es beim
wald gipfel heute ging bis vor kurzem
standen hier 120 jahre alte eichen wegen
dürre und schädlingen musste
waldbesitzer gott und dreht sie abholzen
mit wesentlich geringerem ertrag als
erhofft deutschlandweit sind 277 1000
hektar wald abgestorben mit mischwald
sollen die flächen nun aufgeforstet
werden
preetz hat schon ahorn birke und lärche
gepflanzt
wir tragen dafür sorge dass hier
zukünftig ein klima stabiler wald steht
und dafür brauchen wir diese
unterstützung alleine schaffen wir das
nicht denn es wird einige zeit dauern
bis er mit dem neu gepflanzten wald geld
verdient in dieser übergangszeit will
der staat nun helfen ministerin klöckner
hier beim weltgipfel in sachsen anhalt
will die leistung der waldbesitzer mit
prämien anerkennen dass man pro hektar
der zertifiziert ist der hektar wald
dann auch dem wald besitzen dann etwas
zukommen lässt ihn unterstützt quasi ihm
die ökosystem leistung für uns alle auch
honorieren wird
naturschützer begrüßen das fordern aber
auch strenge bedingungen für die
prämienvergabe sie dürfen nur dorthin
fließen wo wirklich auch das geld
gebraucht wird das geld ist begrenzt die
situation ist sehr ernst und deswegen
ist es wichtig diese mittel eben auch
ganz gezielt einzusetzen
gefördert werden dürfe demnach nur was
auch den ökologischen zustand des waldes
langfristig verbessert also prämien oben
sozusagen unterstützung zu leisten das
was sie gesagt haben auch nochmal
dargestellt durch die bundesministerin
dargestellt aber frau heinen esser
ich frag mal ganz spontan kommt das
nicht alles ein bisschen spät dieses
umdenken denn
selbst wenn man das fördert dauert es ja
auch noch lange bis das sozusagen
effekte zeit
wir werden uns ja von anfang an fördern
also so ist hoffentlich das system so
wird sich das system hoffentlich
entwickelt man als verein ist es so dass
die nadelbäume fast zur hälfte zerstört
sind 40 prozent der fichte von dem
holzhammer auf die waldbesitzer gelebt
sind zerstört und das heißt ich muss
mich weil es wieder aufgeforstet werden
und damit das funktioniert hilft diese
prämie tatsächlich und wieder auf
hausmittel werden wir auch zur verfügung
stellen aber nur noch unter der
bedingung dass hier nicht mehr nur
einseitig nageln wald gepflanzt wird der
eben tatsächlich mit dem klima
schwierigkeiten sondern es muss ein
klima stabiler mich schreibt sein sowie
der waldbesitzer ist hat in ihrem
beitrag auch gesagt hat genau das ist
eben was frau klöckner gesagt hat also
die waldbesitzer sollen unterstützt
werden die besonders klima feste wälder
an pflanzen die soll mit geld belohnt
werden jetzt sagen aber manche ökologen
das ist eigentlich vielleicht der
falsche weg nicht unbedingt neu
anpflanzen nicht in wald umbauen mit
anderen bäumen kunst fall schaffen
vielleicht fremde bäume aus australien
kanada etc sondern den heimischen wald
eine chance geben sich selber anzupassen
sich selber klima festzumachen also
bäume stehen lassen auch umgefallene
bäume chart bäume schadholz usw drin zu
lassen um den wald dichter zu machen das
ist das wo ökologen sagen das ist nicht
nur aus wo wir doch einen anderen weg
vorschlagen was sagen sie denn dazu
zwei seelen in meiner brust zum thema
erstmal geht es darum was wir die
flächen jetzt wirklich zerstört sind und
wir alle kennen die bilder aus den
heimischen wäldern
da ist gar nichts mehr das sind wie sie
sagt und 270 280.000 hektar wie wieder
aufgeforstet werden müssen und ich würde
uns auch empfehlen hier wirklich wieder
aufzuforsten und nicht alles sich selber
zu überlassen und dann mal gucken was da
hinterher bei rauskommen soll das halte
ich für einen fehler hier muss es klar
wieder aufgeforstet
sicherlich kann man aber echte natur
bestimmt
stellen wachsen laster spricht überhaupt
nichts aber es geht auch darum dass die
waldbesitzer ja auch einkommen
generieren sollen aus ihrem und deshalb
bin ich eine mischung haben auch eine
mischung aus förder das system aber über
alle muss stehen dass der bezug und
einen anreiz sein muss eine klima
stabiler und vor allen dingen ein
einheit der biodiversität zulässt
frau ministerin denn dann können wir
ganz ganz ganz herzlich entschuldigen
uns dass da so ein bisschen ist in der
leitung knackt aber wir haben die
wesentlichen punkte von ihnen bekommen
und danken ganz herzlich für das
gespräch und werden das natürlich weiter
verfolgen und jetzt auch noch ein
bisschen weiter diskutieren aber vielen
vielen dank grüße nach nordrhein
westfalen ja wie gesagt wir wollen das
weiter besprechen beim nationalen wald
gipfel waren nicht nur politiker sondern
eben auch waldbesitzer und wald experten
wissenschaftler experten und wir wollen
mit zwei solchen männern auch sprechen
und zwar einmal mit dem fonds experten
lutz feser der uns von südlich von
lübeck zugeschaltet ist ich grüße sie
ganz herzlich und frage jetzt als erstes
mal wo sitzen sie unter welchem baum
ich sitze im garten des ehemaligen
forstamtes der hansestadt lübeck
das war mein dienstsitze da darf ich
jetzt auch leben solange ich will und
hinter mir sehen sie einen stamm eine
esskastanie die wir beim 1 kima
gepflanzt haben und die uns immer mit
guten früchten versorgt ein also ein
klima stabiler in anführungsstrichen
baum so wird er eingeschätzt mit
gleichzeitig ökosystemleistungen essbare
müsse also so dass das ist sozusagen die
wollmilchsau im wald hervorragend und
dann haben wir ebenfalls im wald findet
sehr charmant von ihnen beiden nämlich
einen prominenten waldbesitzer in bayern
hubert aiwanger wir kennen sie als
stellvertretenden ministerpräsidenten
wir es kennen sie als
wirtschaftsminister
heute sprechen sie aber auch als
waldbesitzer einen schönen guten abend
ich grüße sie
erst mal eine frage an herrn feser feser
was halten sie denn von den beschlüssen
die es heute beim nationalen wald gipfel
gegeben hat von dem plan der
bundesministerin klöckner waldbesitzer
zu belohnen die besonders klima feste
wälder schaffen an pflanzen erhalten das
klingt ja erst mal alles ganz gut und
die ministerin aus nordrhein westfalen
hat dem ja gerade auch beigepflichtet
ja ich bin sehr froh dass der diskurs
eröffnet wurde das also nicht nur die
ministerium alleine entscheiden sondern
das wirklich experten und
wissenschaftler und sonstige erfahrene
hinzu kommen dürfen allein die auswahl
heutige war immer noch sehr nach dem
landwirtschaftsministerium die das
landwirtschaftsministerium fast wald ja
als forst auf und im wesentlichen als
produktionsstätte für viel holz aber
immerhin der austausch war gut und
wichtig und auch der tenor ist richtig
dass man nämlich waldbesitzer die ohne
etwas dafür zu können ihren wald
verlieren dass man sie anleitet in
anderer weise und unterstützt auch
finanziell zukunftsfähige wälder zu
lassen wobei ich sage bauen machen hin
pflanzen ist aus meiner sicht erst der
zweite oder dritte weg der erste weg ist
zu gucken was ist von der natur aus dort
möglich und nötig und sich dann
einzufügen denn es geht darum dass
wälder überleben
dass sie vital werden und nicht dass sie
ganz schnell in landwirtschaftlicher
weise wieder in produktion gesetzt
werden
also da würden sie sagen so ja dann kann
auch noch der natur ein bisschen mehr
spielraum einzureichen zu räumen herr
aiwanger die ministerin
frau bundesministerin frau klöckner sagt
der wald ist unser bester mit kämpfer
gegen den klimawandel da sind wir uns ja
alle einig keine frage aber wie will man
diesen mitkämpfer den wald stark machen
pflanzen sie jetzt bei sich im wald
klima festere bäume andere bäume statt
kiefer und fichte sozusagen andere
laubbäume
ich sage ganz ehrlich wenn man nur
wüsste was
bis 50 bis 100 jahren die richtige
baumart ist und wenn wir jetzt hören
dass zertifiziert werden soll und uns
experten sagen welche bäume wir pflanzen
sollen dann haben die die es ja die
letzten 100 150 jahre auch schon gemacht
vor 100 jahren hat es geheißen fichten
monokultur ist das richtige vor 40
jahren nur noch buche zu pflanzen jetzt
stellen wir fest die fichten monokultur
wird vom borkenkäfer gefressen die buche
hat unter trockenheit zu leiden und geht
genauso kaputt wenn es zu trocken wird
sie haben vorher die 120 jährigen eichen
aufgezählt die jetzt an trockenschäden
zugrunde gehen und das sind aber genau
die bäume die die letzten jahre
empfohlen worden sind laut boeing und
dann kommen noch schädlinge hinzu die
auch gezielt laubbäume fressen
ich glaube wir müssen hier gezielt
mischwald machen dass von jeder sorte
was dabei ist und das risiko zu streuen
aber kein hoch bezahlte experte wird uns
heute sagen können was in 30 oder 50
jahren für das dann vorherrschende klima
und die dann vorher schon den
schädlingen wirklich das richtige ist
und auch was der markt wirklich will den
voll am markt vorbeiproduzieren kann man
auch einen waldbesitzer nicht zumuten
ist vielleicht die heutige prämie ganz
nett aber in 30 jahren hat er nur noch
brennholz auch dass wir wollen wir ja
nicht und wir sehen dass die fichte
immer noch als schnittholz nötig ist
also nadelschnittholz will der welt mord
will die heimische zimmerer
damit macht er seinen dachstuhl wenn wir
nur noch eberesche und buche haben wird
der sich nicht freuen darüber also die
richtige mischung macht's jetzt sagt
einer userin ecke penn über youtube geht
in ihre richtung sagt also zu den
vorteilen von mischwäldern tannen und
fichten lassen zu viel licht auf den
boden so trocknet alles aus ohne blätter
ein wald mit blättern hält aber die
feuchtigkeit im boden und sorgt für gute
luft und regen also ein plädoyer eben
auch für den mischwald würden sie denn
in die richtung gehen herr feser und
sagen ja es ist schwer den experten
irgendwie jetzt etwas abzugewinnen
prognosen sind schwer zu machen sagen
sie dann
einfach sozusagen streuen oder sagen sie
der natur das irgendwie überlassen was
aber natürlich dann wiederum für den
waldbesitzer schwierig ja auch noch geld
verdienen will
ja also ich bin ganz vorher aiwanger hat
etwas gesagt was ich voll unterstreiche
wir wissen heute nicht was in der
zukunft durchhält und wir wissen auch
nicht was in 100 jahren auf dem markt
besonders gut bezahlt wird das ist alles
kaffeesatzleserei
wir wissen aber sehr wohl aus der
vergangenheit bis heute in welcher weise
sich natürliche waldökosysteme
entwickeln wir haben den bayerischen
wald zum beispiel also wir brauchen nur
den leiter des bayerischen nationalparks
zu fragen er sagt uns ganz genau bei uns
haben sich ohne dass wir etwas getan
haben die heimischen baumarten wunderbar
bewährt jetzt auch im klimawandel auch
die buche auch die eiche wenn sie nur
richtig behandelt werden wenn sie also
nicht dauernd aufgeschlagen werden dann
wenn man nicht da uns zu viel holz
rausholt wenn man ihnen gestattet die
mischung die es sehr gut die macht die
natur nämlich selber wenn man ihnen
gestattet eine natürliche mischung zu
entwickeln dann leben sie nach dem
überlebensprinzip und es geht im moment
nach überleben und das macht uns die
natur vor
also dieses machen gucken institute
beauftragen den wunderbaum hat den
nächsten zu identifizieren wie die
douglasie oder irgend einen baum aus
nordafrika was er jetzt überall
geschieht ist falsch natürliche
entwicklung fördern beobachten und wo es
hapert gerne auch noch nach pflanzen
aber nicht primär etwas machen und
abschieben und pflanzen also sie sagen
die natur ist sozusagen der beste
förster des waldes um einen klima
robusten wald zu schaffen
ja also in der natur wälder gibt es 300
millionen jahren und die haben sich
immer wieder konstituiert bei jeder
störung es gibt dauernd störungen und
was wir als förster eigentlich unsere
kunst ist nicht wälder zu machen sondern
unsere kunst ist die bestehenden wälder
beziehungsweise gut konstituierte wälder
natürliche naturnahe wälder so zu
begleiten und aus ihnen produkte zu
entnehmen dass sie es kaum merken dass
sie nicht in ihrer produktivität und
überlebensfähigkeit gestört werden das
ist unsere kunst wenig schön pflegen
liegen von wäldern ist sozusagen
eigentlich immer stören also wir müssen
unsere pflege zurückfahren und die
vitalität der wälder die
eigenentwicklung fördern aber nicht
machen machen machen wir einfach so ein
bisschen in die richtung was er jetzt
sagt greenpeace heute auch lobte das
sind sie wollen wir uns hier alle einig
klöckners ziel mehr laubmischwälder
sozusagen zu fördern dafür gelder
auszugeben
die könnten aber nur entstehen sagt auch
greenpeace heute sagen die
umweltschützer wenn das schadholz der
natur überlassen wird statt aus dem wald
transportiert zu werden
aber abgestorbene bäume jetzt einfach
dem wald überlassen oder einfach alle
möglichen bäume stehen lassen damit der
wald dichter enger schattiger wird etc
das bringt dem waldbesitzer ja wieder
kein geld ihnen richtig ja natürlich ist
dies ein ökologisches faktum dass sich
gewisse insekten orten pilze und so
weiter auf totholz ansiedeln aber auf
der anderen seite müsse man hier auch
nicht übers ziel hinaus schießen wenn es
pläne gibt zehn prozent der wälder
stillzulegen oder 10% totholz im wald zu
belassen
dann muss ich sagen können wir uns das
leisten solange wir erdöl verheizen
heizöl verheizen um wärme zu gewinnen
und draußen lassen wir das holz
verfaulen und genau so sehe ich es mit
dem thema jahr die wälder nur sich
selber überlassen die eichen die wir
heute ehren die 150 jahre alt sind die
gebe es in den meisten fällen nicht wenn
die pflegende hand des fürst das und
waldbauern nicht die eiche damals vor
buchen geschützt hätte eine buche die
sehr viel schneller wächst da ist die
eiche die über wächst die also die
eichen wer nicht da sondern wir hätten
buchen monokultur in vielen gebieten
wenn man nicht im jugend stadium des
waldes gewisse baumarten fördert die
viel licht benötigen und die schaden
baumarten zurückdrängt und umgekehrt
also ich bin der überzeugung wir kommen
nicht daran vorbei auch auf den jugend
im jugend stadium des waldes gezielt
einzugreifen und das thema holz
verfallen zu lassen in gewissem umfang
ja aber bitte nicht meinen es ist super
toll wenn unsere wälder vor sich hin
faulen und wir kaufen er durchaus
arabien
also es ist sehr sehr interessant zwei
unterschiedliche meinungen
auch unsere user gehen in
unterschiedliche richtungen iphone 5g
schreibt über youtube schonen
selbstregulation einfach wirken lassen
mehr wald und weniger baum plantagen
patricia bernhard stimmten fehse auch
ein bisschen zu bäume wachsen und
sterben aber sie würden sich niemals
alleine fällen hört einfach auf die
ganze natur für beton und stahl zu
zerstören pflanzt und lasst das ganze
einfach wachsen auf der anderen seite
ärger kriegen sie auch unterstützung
über youtube es beschreibt
forstwirtschaft ist eine wirtschaft und
kein emotionaler krisenherd die alle
unternehmer muss man sich auf ändernde
bedingungen anpassen ich bin
zuversichtlich private unternehmen
können das auch also dass man einfach
darauf reagiert wir hören uns einfach
mal noch eine meinung an
denn wir haben mit professor robert
huber seidl gesprochen des ersten
österreichischer forstwissenschaftler an
der tu münchen und der blickt auf beide
nämlich auf den wald und auch die
waldbesitzer also ökologisch gesprochen
sehen wir dass ich eigentlich fast alle
dieser flächen
die hier vorgestellten gekennzeichnet
waren ich wieder sehr kurz war jünger
das heißt es wächst wieder weit nach
bald danach wächst ist möglicherweise
nicht mehr dasselbe der vorher dort
gestanden ist aber ökologisch gesprochen
würde ich das jetzt mal noch nicht dass
katastrophe einstufen aber aus
menschlicher perspektive der meisten
beispiel die perspektive der wald
besitzerinnen und besitzer sogar da ist
das natürlich ein beträchtlicher schaden
und den gibt es jetzt auch entsprechend
wieder auszugleichen beziehungsweise
auch eben die bilder darauf
vorzubereiten dass in zukunft solche
extremereignisse der durchaus häufiger
vorkommen könnte herr feser greifen das
einfach mal auf muss man nicht doch
verständnis haben für waldbesitzer wir
zum beispiel ein alpha der eben sagt ich
kann jetzt nicht alles hier vor sich hin
faulen lassen und der natur das
überlassen ich muss ja doch irgendwo die
stellen die total kahl sind wieder
aufforsten ich muss da streuen aber ich
muss ja auch irgendwo mit dem holz und
auch geld machen und daran denken dass
ich da irgendwie auch noch sozusagen ein
bisschen profit mache und was der
holzmarkt möchte
ja also dass das ist völlig richtig
sofern wir wald als wirtschaftswald
betrachten gibt es das recht des
waldbesitzers das zu erwarten dass die
wirtschaftsbedingungen stimmen aber
genau das ist heute glaube ich ein wenig
verfehlt worden
in dem wald gipfel dass man gesagt genau
da müssen wir den waldbesitzern helfen
wir müssen ihm nicht helfen mit großen
maschinen und neu gekauften pflanzen und
den neuen wunderbar matten der zukunft
nun die wälder zu räumen und eine
sozusagen eine landwirtschaft mit
verholzen den pflanzen zu machen sondern
wir müssen die da unterstützen wo der
wald seine vitalität bekommt nämlich in
der natürlichen entwicklung und wenn ein
waldbesitzer seine pflichten verloren
hat sagen wir weil die förster in was
empfohlen haben immer nur fichten zu
bauen wollte es vielleicht gar nicht
dann muss er entschädigt werden dass das
jetzt nicht mehr produktiv ist und
erwarten darf und kann sagen wir mal
zehn jahre gucken was sich ansiedelt und
dann vielleicht vorsichtig nach pflanzen
aber genau dieses also der natur den
ersten schritt zu lassen und der natur
zu folgen damit die vitalität der wälder
über die natur entsteht dafür sind an
subventionen da und dafür sollte heute
der gipfel eigentlich den startschuss
geben unterstützt die waldbesitzer dass
die natur sich wieder erholen kann
denn natur kann sich nicht auf den
menschen einstellen menschen müssen sich
aber auf die natur auf die naturgesetze
einstellen und die naturgesetze kann die
natur nur silber hervorbringen und
aufgrund dieser naturgesetze wachsen
also der der zungenschlag heute war
wieder falsch wir gehen mit industrie
und maschinen und viel geld rein und
machen einen wald wie uns professor ickx
und professor y empfiehlt und nach 20 30
jahren wissen wir dass es wahrscheinlich
nicht richtig war
statt zu sagen wie würde natur die das
so komplex macht wie wir menschen es nie
machen könnten wie würde die natur das
machen und auf diesem weg unterstützen
wir auch als bundesregierung durch
subventionen entgangene gewinne
vereinfachen hat dann einfach die frage
an sie nur als beispiel
sie sind ja jetzt waldbesitzer wäre das
nicht auch eine möglichkeit zu sagen
dass man prämien kriegt für ich sag
jetzt mal die tonne co2 die gebunden
wird nach dem motto dass man sie mit
einer prämie animiert sozusagen nicht
abzuholzen nicht
verkaufen zu müssen sondern einfach den
wald zb dichter werden zu lassen
ich glaube auf alle fälle dass man dem
waldbesitzer weiterhin zugestehen sollte
mit dem wald auch geld zu verdienen den
wirtschaftswelt das sind am ende wenn
sie richtig bewirtschaftet werden
durchaus die stabileren welt und auch im
sinne des klimaschutzes am besten wenn
wir reife bohémien ich habe heute in der
oberpfalz ein wunderschönes blockhaus
wie wichtig das aus douglasie vielleicht
nicht ganz korrekt im sinne von forst
ideologen die douglasie außer einer
douglasie ein riesen blockhaus gebaut
hat und dann eben in den wäldern wieder
junge bäume nachwachsen dann haben wir
co2 in dem blockhaus gespeichert und
haben das neue co2 wieder in den bäumen
die dort nachwachsen
und wenn wir das bauen von mit holz oder
die nutzung von holz generell
diskreditieren und dieses haus aus beton
gemacht wird anstatt aus holz am klavier
an der stelle auch nichts gewonnen also
die nutzung der wälder für dort austria
auch robuster sind wir müssen auch im
jugend stadium bäume entfernen damit die
sich ordentlich entwickeln können
wurzeln und kronen entwickeln können und
nicht bei vier wochen trockenheit dann
kaputt gehen weil sie nur eine ganz
kleine wurzel haben und fast keine
blätter oder keine krone haben also ich
bin der überzeugung richtige aufklärung
und auch da habe es vielleicht den satz
noch dass immer mehr waldbesitzer volt
vom vater oder großvater erben selber in
der stadt wohnen gar nicht mehr wissen
wo die wälder sind mit einer motorsäge
umgehen können und dann 30 jahre die
wälder vor sich hin gammeln bis es der
käfer frist und alle sind sich
zusammenbricht und dann ist das große
wehklagen da stehen die türen bei mehrum
aber die bäume können eben nicht alle
auf demselben platz stehen ein teil muss
entfernt werden und die bewirtschaftung
ist nach wie vor ökologisch zu
verantworten
da muss ich jetzt die reckenfelder
fragen sehen sie das genauso
nein natürlich gar nicht also herzlich
hat sich jetzt eine ganz andere richtung
erklärt nehme ich eben ebendieses machen
mit douglasien usw
also dieses dieses agrar induzierte
machen
ich bin überhaupt nicht gegen das nutzen
von wäldern aber es geht primär darum
die existenz möglichkeit der wälder zu
fördern und wir wissen dass wir etwa 80
prozent der wälder in deutschland sind
natur fern in der struktur und in den
baumarten wir haben etwa 50% nadelbäume
von natur hätten wir keine fünf prozent
in deutschland
das hab ich bin überhaupt nicht dagegen
dass wir diese jähnigen bäume die hier
nicht in das ökosystem reinpassen und
die jetzt natürlich logischerweise auch
sterben wie fichten douglasien lärchen
und so weiter das für sie langsam zurück
bauen dass wir dann aber die
neubesiedlung mit den heimischen
baumarten die sich gut anpassen können
nach ökologischer weise begleiten unsere
wälder sind alle magersüchtig wir haben
nur etwa die hälfte in unseren
wirtschaftswäldern anbau masse wie sie
in einem naturwald in einem urwald wäre
wir haben 350 kubikmeter projekt in
deutschland im schnitt hätten aber etwa
700 kubikmeter in einem naturbelassenen
weil das heißt unsere wälder sind an der
kante die die sind viel zu mager und in
dieser situation wo sie noch zusatz
stress kriegen wie zum beispiel jetzt
den klimawandel können wir nicht sagen
wir müssen jetzt noch mehr raus hauen
und die krone noch mehr groß machen dann
schlagen wir die wälder heiß der boden
wird trocken wir müssen der natur
abgucken wie sie überleben und nicht dem
holzhandel abgucken wie viel holz sie
brauchen wald kann sich nicht auf den
menschen einstellen nein wir müssen uns
auf die natur einstellen
herr aiwanger das ist ja sehr konträr zu
dem was sie sagen
außerdem hätte ich dann auch noch die
frage wir haben das gerade sie haben das
gerade sehr schön ja gesagt wie toll das
ist wenn eine douglasie in bayern
gefällt wird und dann zu einem holzhaus
in bayern verwandelt wird aber das
problem ist ja auch gleichzeitig wir
haben sind beitrag angehen schon gehört
dass unmengen deutsches holz exportiert
wird in die usa nach china und der
deutsche zimmerer sogar das große
problem hat an das holz zu kommen aus
ihrem wald wie passt das alles zusammen
jetzt auch zu dem was er feser sagt dass
sozusagen die wälder magersüchtig sind
also sozusagen zu viel holz auch aus
geholt wird
also ich will hier noch mal kurz
antworten dieses blockhaus war eben
jetzt aus douglasie
jetzt könnt ihr auch aus heimischer
tonne sein oder fichte aber es wird
nicht aus der buche sein können
weil diese bäume nicht gerade genug
boxen auch für den dachstuhl bilder
zimmer nadelschnittholz und eben nicht
buchenholz also die verteufelung des
nordens holzes ist falsch und wir haben
durchaus standorte wo nadelholz standort
typisch autochthon vorkommt und dort
sich auch selber wieder verjüngt wenn
wir dort mit buch ihrer in gehen haben
wir den kahlfrost und die bäume
verschwinden und genau so will ich
dieses hinterfragen das heißt je mehr
kubikmeter holz auf dem hektar stehen
umso stabiler vieri dieser wollt es
kommt eben nur gewisser anteil von
regeln auf diese quadratmeter runter und
wenn wir oben total dichte kronen dächer
haben kommt kein tropfen auf den boden
herunter hin und wieder etwas
aufgelockert es strukturen wo auch mal
ein sonnenstrahl nach unten kommt dass
unten auch mal heidelbeeren wächst
brombeere wächst strohig erwachsen ist
besser ist beispielsweise eine buchen
monokultur wo ich nur 20 cm hoch laub
und du aber das was er meint dass auch
dass herr vermeintlicher keiner aus
durch sieht das was herr feser meint ist
ja keine buch von mode und kultur weil
er ja gerade setzt sich eben aber die
setzt sich vielfach durchgesetzt sich
vielfach durch wenn der mensch nicht
eingreift und der jungen eichen hilft
dann überlebt dort nur die buchener
haben sie hektar weise nur die buche
dann kommt der maikäfern frist ihnen die
buche weg oder es kommt am ende eine
trockenperiode dann geht die buche
genauso drauf wie die fichte also die
richtige mischung macht's und in der
jugend zu pflegen ist immer besser wie
alle sich selber zu überlassen
also da stelle ich fest dass sind sehr
konträre meinungen herr aiwanger sagt
der mensch kann das am besten richten
das ökologische ausgeglichenste system
schafft der mensch und herr fischer sie
sagen wenn man doch millionen jahre
zurückschaut sagen sie die natur kann
der mensch nicht toppen
wir merken ja eine diskussion der
borkenkäfer ist in den natürlichen
waldgebieten in denen also die
die heimischen bäume in einer mischung
da sind überhaupt kein problem dann gibt
es da gar nicht der borkenkäfer ist nach
über deutschland verbreitet worden
dadurch dass überall fichten und andere
nadelbäume gepflanzt und die von natur
aus nicht vorkommen natürlich gibt es in
den bayerischen alpen gibt es da
fürchten natürlich und da sollen sie
auch weiter bleiben aber dass das dreht
sich also wirklich immer wieder um diese
frage machen wir viel oder lassen wir zu
also dieses dieses märchen zb dass ein
dichter wald kein kein wasser von oben
nach unten runterlässt das wird
kolportiert ohne dass man das
verifizieren kann im wald hier dichter
einheimischer laubmischwald ist desto
feuchter ist er weil nämlich die
feuchtigkeit die von oben eindringt in
diesem feuchten winter armen und kühlen
milieu ganz lange erhalten bleibt und
wer mal im wald war und nicht über wald
redet nur sondern wirklich drin war der
weiß in einem gewitter oder einem
ordentlichen regenschauer das im sommer
das wasser an den buchen stemmen oder
auch an den ahorn stemmen wie ein
wasserfall runter läuft dann sind alle
stämme dunkel und die buch erholt sich
wie in einem trichter das wasser direkt
in die wurzel rainha das braucht er an
sich links und rechts neben dem baum und
im winter ist bei uns in deutschland
sind die laubbäume karl und da fällt der
regen einfach durch und es ist ganz
wichtig dass im winter das wasser war
aufgefüllt wird
diejenigen die glauben dass in der krone
den regen abhält die kennen das
vielleicht von den fichtenwäldern nicht
aber das sind keine drei prozent in der
natürlichen ausgestaltung das heißt
viele viele märchen werden erzählt weil
man ökologisch im wald sich nicht
auskennen auch zb das breit dass
breitschlagen also die kronen alle
freistellen bedeutet dass sie im sommer
eine erbärmliche hitze haben
in den dazwischen liegenden gebieten und
wir wissen auch mittlerweile dass die
spitzenbelastungen im klimawandel jetzt
entscheidend sind also die spitzen hitze
an ein zwei drei tagen und nicht die
kontinuität das heißt das bereitstellen
von bäumen ist eine zusätzliche
belastung im klimawandel
während das dunkel werden lassen
einhalten von feuchte- und von kühle ist
und fördert im übrigen im übrigen die
natürliche haltung
wie gesagt von von wäldern an an dichte
und an dunkelheit die es uns eigentlich
ein maßstab was optimal wäre die natur
optimiert das ganze und wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir dieses optimum durch
intensives schlagen und öffnen nicht
verfehlen dann noch mal die frage an
herrn aiwanger es gibt auch user die
ihnen zur seite springen tmh half
schreibt über youtube womit sollen den
fonds besitzer künftig geld verdienen
nadelholz ist was die papier und holz
industrie braucht das habe ich einfach
mal gehört also sozusagen auch eine
meinung die dahin geht dass der
waldbesitzer ja nun auch damit etwas
verdienen soll aber trotzdem einfach
noch mal die frage wir haben es gehört
viel holz wird auch exportiert wenn ich
jetzt das nehme was herr feser sagt dann
wundere ich mich doch dass wir holz aus
den wäldern rausholen herr feser sagt da
könnten mehr bäume stehen
der wald sei derzeit magersüchtig ein
problem und dann wird das holz aber
nicht mal benutzt in deutschland sondern
nach china und usa exportiert wie ist
das denn ganz so zu bewerten oder würden
sie sagen nein
in der tat ein exportstopp oder
irgendwas in richtung wäre auch sinnvoll
natürlich ist holz auch ein export den
finanz- wirtschafts- produkt und wir
müssen wir müssen froh sein dass in der
vergangenheit auch die amerikanischen
märkte beispielsweise deutsches
käferholz gekauft hat also holz das hier
im überfluss vorhanden wollen und nach
wie vor im überfluss vorhanden ist
teilweise noch im türen zustand in den
wäldern steht und nicht mal geerntet
wird weil der holzhacker teurer ist als
der erlös die amerikaner haben gott sei
dank jetzt höhere preise auch für dieses
holz bezahlt die ist der heimische markt
gar nicht aufgerufen hat diese hohen
preise
damit sind diese bäume auch überhaupt
vom markt wahr geworden und damit
verdient der säger damit verdient auch
der waldbesitzer weil er die ware
überhaupt los bekommt und kann damit
wieder neue wälder begründen so viel
brennholz könnten wir gar nicht brauchen
wie momentan die amerikaner kaufen
natürlich geht das mittlerweile zu
lasten der heimischen zimmerer die hier
von diesem export quasi
aufgesaugt werden und ihre verträge mit
dem häuslebauer nicht mehr erfüllen
können
wir müssen also hier dieses markt
gleichgewicht wieder herstellen müssen
die heimischen wertschöpfungsketten
wieder auf gesunde beine stellen
aber dieser boom holz nach amerika wird
nicht dauernd anhalten das ist
vielleicht jetzt ein jahr weil einfach
die amerikaner auch massive
konjunkturprogramme aufgelegt haben weil
jeder sein eigenes holzhaus bauen will
auch in corona zeit nicht mehr miete
wohnen will und wenn dieser spuk vorüber
ist dann werden wir vielleicht in ein
paar jahren wieder froh sein wenn der
export markt überhaupt wieder heimische
ware abnimmt
frage an herrn feser sehen sie das auch
so dass der markt sich da irgendwie
regelt angebot und nachfrage und wenn
mal die nachfrage in den usa und china
großes dann ist das so das wird sich
auch wieder ändern
na ja der markt hat sich ja nicht
geregelt wir sehen ja jetzt das enorme
display täten entstanden sind also die
wenn sie jetzt ein haus bauen wollen
hier in deutschland zahlen sie das drei
bis fünffache für nadelholz bauholz
während der waldbesitz davon gar nichts
hat also der waldbesitzer kriegt maximal
das was er einst so viele vor vier oder
fünf jahren gekriegt hat aber also
maximal 90 euro pro kubikmeter rohholz
schlichte aber hat in der zwischenzeit
30 oder 40 nur gekriegt das heißt hier
ist eine display steht auf dem markt und
hier die us regierung gefordert das kann
der einzelne nicht regeln hier ist
regierung gefordert dass er den markt
ein wenig regel dass er das holz ihr
list und nicht sagt ihr deutschen
müssten noch mehr holz schlagen damit in
china und den usa noch mehr und billig
gebaut werden kann also hier hier läuft
etwas ganz ganz falsch und es wäre im
sinne von ökologischer behutsamkeit und
auch verdienstmöglichkeit von
waldbesitzern ganz gut man hätte sich
den markt geteilt man hätte quasi die
hälfte der bäume liegen oder stehen
lassen das ist kein mucks diese bäume
dichter liegen oder stehen bleiben das
ist eine grundbedingung für ein gutes
entwickeln von zukünftigen wäldern der
steht nämlich humus daraus das wasser
wird gehalten und viele mikroorganismen
und sonstige tiere die für das
wohlergehen des waldes wichtig sind das
sind nicht nur museale stücke sondern es
ein teil des ökosystems sich ketten
hierher
hier bleiben können und die andere
hälfte vielleicht hätte vermarktet
werden können und die die defizite die
dem waldbesitzer dadurch entstehen bzw
das wohltuenden co2 bereich hier zu
erhalten und die wälder dichter werden
zu lassen und mehr co2 dadurch
herunterzuholen
die kann man dann entlohnen als
ökosystem die dienstleistung aber nicht
immer wieder neu mit großer kraft
irgendwas machen sondern honorieren dass
das was hier ist an humus und anbau
masse und an co2 speicherung
dass das hier der menschheit und dem
wald zu gute kommt herr feser vielen
vielen dank ich habe ein sozusagen
zustimmendes worte eben meinem ohr
gehört von ihnen herr aiwanger dass sie
sagen in der tat da stimmen sie herrn
feser zu da kommt gar nicht so viel
durch diese nachfragen durch den export
bei ihnen bei den waldbesitzern an das
heißt also sie werden jetzt auch nicht
gerade reich weil in amerika oder china
viel deutsches holz gebraucht wird
ansonsten haben wir wollen ihnen gelernt
ein bisschen doch unterschiedliche
strategien und sichtweisen aber hoch
spannend sehr interessant und insofern
wird es ja weiter diskussionen geben wie
wir den wald als klimaschützer stärken
können gegen den klimawandel was man am
besten macht es war hochinteressant mit
ihnen beiden zu sprechen und ist ein
großes dankeschön an herrn feser an sie
grüße in den hohen norden
genießen sie noch die abendsonne unter
der kastanie und der ellwanger wir
danken ihnen auch ganz ganz herzlich
liebe grüße nach bayern sehr großes
dankeschön dass sie sich zeit genommen
haben und weiterhin alles gute ihnen und
ihren bäumen im hintergrund ganz
herzlichen dank sagen ja und bei ihnen
bedanke ich mich auch ganz herzlich für
ihr interesse für das mitdiskutieren
das war glaube ich sehr erhellend und
sehr interessant mehr noch zu erfahren
was es für meinungen gibt von
waldbesitzern von politikern und auch
forstexperten nach diesem nationalen
wald gipfel die diskussionen werden
weitergehen wir bleiben dran und ich
sage danke schön und einen schönen abend
noch